benvenuti al museo nazionale della
scienza e della tecnologia leonardo da
vinci di milano da qui parte il mio
viaggio con questo speech dal titolo
guida galattica per
giovani disorientati in era post
lockdown è un titolo volutamente leggero
proprio perché usciamo da un periodo
quello della pandemia dell'emergenza
sanitaria
estremamente pesante denso di paura e
con questo mio discorso vorrei lanciare
appunto ai giovani disorientati di oggi
un messaggio universale perché poi di
fatto questo galattico e non è altro che
un accenno a l'universalità del
messaggio che vorrei
comunicare allora la il nostro viaggio
parte da una piccola città della
provincia di varese che si chiama
saronno dove lo trovo le mie origini un
luogo saronno privo di una conformazione
identitaria specifica e che non mi ha
trasmesso nessun particolare senso di
appartenenza l'aneddoto che io ricordo
sempre in relazione alla città dove
appunto trovo le mie origini è il fatto
che io l'ho sempre percepita fin da
bambina con un po un
luogo borderline sempre letto che
saronno è un po new jersey di milano e
poi il fatto particolarmente divertente
che il prefisso telefonico è 0 2
geograficamente la città più vicina e
como e il
la provincia di fatto è varese questo
che sembra diciamo un'inezia agli occhi
di una bambina è particolarmente
divertente proprio perché si intuisce
come questo luogo di fatto galleggia tra
diverse identità non è comasco non è
varesotto ma non è neanche milanese è
forse la mancanza di stimoli li
determinatezza di questo luogo dove
ripeto io sono nata mia in un certo
senso nutrito regalandomi tanta
curiosità tanta intraprendenza tanta
voglia di fare ma soprattutto di uscire
da questa dimensione provinciale ed è
qui che inizia quello che definisco il
grand tour se nel 1700 e nel 1800 i
giovani
si avventuravano in europa e scendevano
da appunto inghilterra germania per
esempio nei luoghi della classicità io
studentessa di anglistica e germanistica
parto dalla facoltà di lingue e
letterature straniere dell'università
cattolica di milano alla volta proprio
di queste regioni della germania
dell'austria e grazie alla vittoria di
una serie di borse di studio la prima a
graz ma già precedentemente avevo
frequentato luoghi come ruote hamburg
monaco norimberga e così via
incomincio diciamo a conoscere ea
esplorare culture altre
il mio gran tour reverse grand tour ha
avuto quindi traiettorie diverse non dal
nord al sud ma dal sud appunto dei
luoghi della classicità come l'italia
verso altre regioni come appunto
l'austria la germania prima appunto a
monaco di baviera a norimberga
a berlino e poi grazie una borsa di
studio vinta presso l'università
cattolica di milano e lo specifico la
facoltà di lingue e letterature
straniere
riesco a frequentare graz e la sua
università
specializzata proprio in
germanistica
questo mio peregrinare molto giovane
questo mio peregrinare che io diciamo
inizio da giovanissima perché avevo poco
più di 19 anni poco più che ventenne
sicuramente mi comporta uno slancio il
fatto di voler e poter uscire dalla mia
con ford l'on
la capacità di allontanarmi da anni
affetti più cari per molto tempo anni
anche di fatto è uscita di casa 19 anni
per poi non tornarci più
mi ha regalato il cosiddetto proverbiale
bagaglio
cosmopolitismo
la possibilità di conoscere una cultura
ricca come quella mitteleuropea e di
entrare in contatto con il
l'utilissimo ed efficientissimo
pragmatismo anglosassone
torno a milano che è il mio baricentro
il mio personale baricentro in questo
viaggio che abbiamo definito red horse
grand tour per raccogliere altre
informazioni altre diciamo possibilità
altre risorse per poi tornare a
viaggiare
vado a scrivere la mia tesi di laurea
per esempio a newcastle upon tyne sempre
dopo aver vinto una borsa di studio
dove conduco la mia tesi di di laurea
proprio su in popolar music studies
newcastle upon tyne dove diciamo spicca
questo dipartimento di popolar music
studies mia prima passione
vengo poi di nuovo
richiamata in italia a milano quindi
torna appunto questo discorso di
baricentro e se guardiamo questa mappa
geografica che io vi sto descrivendo
vediamo proprio questi diciamo fili che
collegano l'europa a milano per poi
ritornare viaggiare di nuovo alla volta
di londra dove
vinco un'altra borsa di studio è di
fatto una borsa lavoro e diventò una
social media manager ante litteram
stiamo parlando degli anni 2000 del 2000
per una azienda che si occupa si
occupava di analisi di mercato
infine decido di
affrontare la grande sfida del dottorato
di ricerca dottorato di ricerca che
conduco vincendo una borsa di studio in
gran bretagna quindi il volo di nuovo
alla volta questa volta di londra dopo
l'esperienza lavorativa a londra grazie
alla sponsorship vinta torno a milano
dove di nuovo vinco una borsa di studio
questa volta per condurre il mio
dottorato di ricerca in sociologia e
metodologia della ricerca sociale che
però deciso di condurre non a milano
maria nuova in gran bretagna dove voglio
approfondire lo studio della sociologia
della cultura e dei fenomeni culturali
grazie alle ricerche condotte proprio a
londra e nel contesto britannico
focalizzandomi sulle paradigmi di
fruizione
musica pop
svolgo attività di ricerca sui consumi
mediali in contesti interculturali
focalizzandomi sui paradigmi di
produzione di fruizione di musica in
background multietnici da questa mia
ricerca nascono due meno grafie from
sounds and sound metz
dopo questo periodo in gran bretagna che
poi si protrae a lungo nel tempo e vivo
a londra per circa 45 anni vengo
richiamata a milano e quindi di nuovo
torno verso il mio vari centro per
incominciare a lavorare presso
l'università cattolica e qui nel 2006
incontro che io un incontro magico
e che andrà a caratterizzare
la seconda parte della mia carriera ed
ecco che in questo viaggio ideale che ha
costruito la mia piccola personale mappa
cartina geografica
troviamo sostanzialmente un po il mio
take away per voi
quello che definisco un po un consiglio
sospeso come il caffè sospeso per tutti
i giovani che hanno vissuto un periodo
quello della emergenza sanitaria e della
pandemia sicuramente
indelebile sicuramente indimenticabile
ma non nel senso positivo del termine
oggi per ricominciare ritengo dalla mia
esperienza che debbono essere messi in
campo tutta una serie di valori come il
coraggio e l'intraprendenza
che dal mio punto di vista
sono dei vaccini contro
probabilmente il problema è l'elemento
più bloccante in questo momento che è la
paura la paura è disabilitante è nemica
della agency ovvero della capacità che
ognuno di noi sa di poter realizzare
anche in maniera generativa e quindi il
mio consiglio sospeso è questo trovate
il vostro baricentro nel mio caso è la
città di milano e l'università cattolica
che mi ha dato tante possibilità e tante
belle occasioni per poi lanciarvi nella
vostra impresa la parola impresa non è
un caso che voglia dire in lingua
italiana abbia due accezioni un qualcosa
sì che si fa con grande sforzo in
maniera anche un po avventurosa come gli
eroi dei romanzi ma anche l'impresa
l'azienda è un'impresa
e che cosa vi può aiutare sicuramente la
curiosità abbiamo già parlato del
coraggio
dell'intraprendenza sono questi i
vaccini alla paura è importante
ricordare che ognuno di noi in un
cassetto in una tasca a un biglietto
stropicciato su cui ha scritto il
proprio sogno è bello averlo è
importante confrontarsi con esso senza
paura con coraggio umiltà e tanta tanta
curiosità ma bisogna avere anche un po
un business plan cioè bisogna avere un
piano di sostenibilità proprio perché
quello che si vuole fare deve essere
sempre sostenuto da reali possibilità a
mio avviso sentimenti bloccanti come
l'ansia la paura l'angoscia devono
essere letteralmente oggi da debellare
con un vaccino speciale poiché intaccano
le gen si dei più giovani e sono il
peggior ostacolo per la loro
realizzazione per la loro crescita
personale e per la loro soddisfazione
bisogna come vi dicevo avere un business
plan oltre c'è un sogno che sia
sostenibile nel medio e lungo termine e
quindi con questo io vi lascio con una
diciamo suggerimento un consiglio
pratico ma anche poetico romantico
bisogna avere come vi dicevo sicuramente
un sogno del cassetto ma che
praticamente ecco questo diciamo un
pragmatismo anglosassone sempre che
torna si possa fare
ringrazio i giovani studenti di tex
unicatt che mi hanno invitato e vi
saluto
grazie a tutti